Blue and white ticket, 9194308, 9194308.
We got one? Awesome. What salon are you from?
We've got a smart tan credit with an Embrace the Sun book.
We've got two of these to give away.
Yellow and white ticket, yellow and white ticket, guys, 5791.
two eight seven three five seven nine one two eight seven three for a smart tan ticket and
embrace the sun book excellent i think the books are behind the counter oh they're other okay
if you want to just bring that up to emily for me thank you congratulations what salon are you from
tuscany studio another yellow and white ticket for another smart tan credit and embrace the sun book
yellow and white ticket five seven nine one two six three nine five seven nine one two six three
nine yellow ticket sprays by rays okay which is what all right is this our last one this is our
last draw this is the employee gift and it is i believe a lululemon bag
i want one all right hopefully nobody claims this one
i'll take it yellow and white yellow and white ticket number five seven nine one
two six eight four who's that's me oh nice and what's the lawn purity congratulations
Congratulations.
So, guys, all of these prizes will, you can see Crystal at the end.
Okay, so Crystal has all your prizes outside.
All right.
So you can claim your prizes from Crystal outside when you're ready to leave.
I hope at this point we've got our product pitch.
I have an announcement.
Hang on, guys.
I've got an announcement.
We've got our product pitch.
Our product pitch results are done.
Hey guys, before I hand out the winners of our product pitch, I just have to say thank you to each and every one of you for making the trip out to Woodstock today.
We love this event because it just gives us a really cool opportunity to connect with you guys, talk some business, but more than anything, just really get to know you and you guys get a chance to know us.
I have to thank all of our vendors who made trips from all over the world in order to be here to support our company, most importantly our country, which I absolutely love.
So thank you to everybody who made the trip up here.
We'll never be the 54th state. Yay Canada!
All right and the most I need oh god
our team here at Uvillage just did such a phenomenal job.
Guys we start planning for this like tomorrow already.
For those who don't know we already are planning for our our expo in January.
It's here on the east coast January 31st so write that in your book right now.
We don't know the theme yet.
Don't, haven't said, nailed the location
but it will be somewhere close to here but that's January
31st. Our team works so
incredibly hard to organize
events like this, to decorate
and put on great
efforts in order to connect with you guys and show you
guys new equipment and talk about products
and help educate you so you can grow your
business. Today especially
was incredibly hard between, is it
raining, is it not, are we inside, are we out, are we
pivoting, we've got a new tent, we've still got
great tents. It was just an absolute
Absolute, just nonstop, pivot, pivot, pivot, pivot.
And the team, everybody you see walking around in our glow shirts did a phenomenal, phenomenal job.
They all deserve a huge round of applause and a great appreciation and thanks from me and everybody here.
Just amazing, amazing, amazing job, guys.
We love what we do, and we do it for you, and this is exactly the reason why we're here.
So thank you so much for coming.
Thank you to the Ublux team, and certainly a thank you to all the vendors.
As I wrap up, I want to invite all of our pitch presenters to appear for a second.
is everybody kind of still floating around up here? The good news is, is we're at UVilex and
we all love each other. I get two microphones, so I'm louder now. Everybody's a winner today,
guys. So every one of our pitch contests, we're going home with something. First of all,
we have our two runner-ups. One runner-up first goes to Daniela. Big round of applause for Daniela.
So take a look for the wall.
And for you.
Our next runner up
in no particular order
goes to Nicole and Ashley.
Good job guys.
Thank you for all your hard work
and your effort.
Our third place winner
and winner of $200 goes to
Brooke. Brooke, where you at?
Good job, Brooke. Wonderful
presentation. Brooke from Miami
Glow. Absolutely awesome.
Second place and $350 goes to our best-dressed couple, Chelsea and Alex.
Congratulations.
Which makes our winner, Miss Sherry Hawk.
Sherry, where you at?
Congratulations. Great job.
Big hugs.
Thank you again, everybody. We will see you back in January.
Please feel free to come any time you want to here.
We're an open shop and come and tan and hang out and just be with us.
we love that otherwise we will see you in January thanks again for being here today please drive
safe and take care of yourselves and be well all right love you all thanks so much okay bye